durans
acredito que eles devem estar curiosos
para saber que tá lá é essa né
realmente foi uma palavra inventada por
ela contém
a associação de duas palavras de zouros
esperança e porque os besouros porque
com tantos insetos que nos remetem a
transformação é como a gente já sabe
também que as borboletas têm papel
importante nesse nosso entendimento mas
os besouros
eles fazem parte de da ordem dos copos
que são insetos que já carrega no seu
nome de origem grega como uma tradução
livre desse entendimento dos besouros um
estojinho de água
estojo é pesado e asas são recursos que
a gente tem pra voar mas aí eu me
interessei mais ainda procura o
entendesse
dentre os insetos besouros dentro de
escolher outros a gente tem aí os
insetos eu escolhi o joaninha não
somente os besouros porque ela é
bonitinha mas ela representa o que a
gente duvida que seja capaz de voar uma
cabeça pequena as pesadas o formato
redondo guerreiro dinâmica por esses
insetos usuário
às vezes dou e foi o entendimento dessa
linha protetiva que tenha uma palavra
pesada uma casca grossa é rígida que não
é esse o movimento que faz os besouros
do ar é uma linha que está por baixo
lembra rosa que é ela que dá permissão
para que esses insetos ter meio ambiente
diversos e na maioria das vezes adversas
e foi entendendo isso que eu encontrei a
necessidade de viver um pouquinho a
atitude dos besouros quando eu encontrei
a morte não pela primeira vez mais uma
forma inimaginável imprevisível que
realmente me fez repensar porque
eu essa menina mineira de belo horizonte
nem nascida de uma família de thais
jovens que tem aí o objetivo de
continuar a vida e eu vi no núcleo
familiar de quatro irmãos
minha mãe teve fez a arte de ter quatro
filhos em dois anos e onze meses fique
tranquila seu irmão gêmeo e depois veio
eu e meu caçula de um shopping e foi
essa menina super protegida mimada
a mãe sempre com as suas asinhas
professora mãe me ajudando a prosseguir
e fiz uma trajetória de vida que eu
posso dizer de muita sorte de boa
educação de boas oportunidades e de novo
teve a sorte aos 18 anos de encontrar o
amor da minha vida estamos juntos até
hoje há 36 anos
sou egresso das ciências médicas
escolheu a medicina como a minha
actividade profissional e permeia as
áreas da pesquisa da medicina preventiva
e também ensina laboratorial e aí
diante de toda essa riqueza profissional
pessoal e familiar
eu tinha um sonho eu tinha um sonho de
ser mãe mas eu falava com a mãe que eu
queria ter um time de handebol futsal
voleibol
eu queria ter muitos filhos e fui
fortemente prestigiada premiada e
privilegiada em ter duas filhas
biológicas que vieram pra completar
aquele núcleo familiar que pra mim era
um quadrado mágico e que nesse sustentou
e me levou a toda a minha caminhada
profissional
eu dei a lusa juliana na áfrica do sul e
isabela minha caçula linha que hoje de
na itália
e foi diante de toda essa oportunidade
de curtir demais a maternidade em que a
gente com o fator sorte sempre me
acompanhando a gente teve uma sorte
invertida na nossa casa
ganhamos uma loteria inverso
o jogo foi acometida de um câncer raro e
nos deixou depois de 90 dias de uma luta
um tanto quanto em totti mas em glória e
nós perdemos
e aí nós somos convidados a entender e
compreender a devolução de um de uma
linda menina aguerrida que foi com a
maior serenidade que a vida que a trouxe
aqui pudesse nos mostrar
ela foi com coragem e foi nesse encontro
com essa fina e tude com essa paralisia
com essa dificuldade de andar
eu me lembrei dos besouros e agora é a
hora de eu usar os recursos nesses
insetos que me ensinam tanto
e aí eu tive que lidar com sentimentos
novos movimentos muito preocupante
porque eu não queria sair da minha cama
aí vem a minha filha sobrevivente que
começa a me convidar mas se você não
sair da cama e tomar café comigo não
rola
opa mãe eu não vou mais a restaurante
com você com papai por que você já
reparou que a gente não tem medo de três
agentes a mesa de padres ué de 2004 ou é
de seis a oito ou então ela é redonda
então vamos arredondar esse negócio dela
nós vamos levar o nosso sim o que ficava
na cama da ju e vamos fazer a nossa
companhia e ele vai participar conosco
de almoços viagens e tac a nossa jude
pelúcia que vem caminhando conosco
e desse momento em diante começaram a
surgir vários sinais sinais
extraterrestres sinais muito marcos
estelares e a gente tem é o primeiro
encontro com uma viagem em que a gente
está na na rodovia e aparece uma placa
com o nome de juliana
eu tive que tirar uma foto não trouxe
aqui pra vocês mas acreditem
essa foto estava lá nós tiramos
registramos então nós começamos a
entender que esse é um momento que a
gente estava sendo convidado aqui a
exercitar besor ansa
puxa vida quantas coisas estavam
tentamos parar ea gente estava só
aprendendo coisas para nos guiar prazer
de prosseguir e aí os sinais vão parar
porque pra passar por tudo isso a gente
não consegue passar sozinho
a gente tem que ter ajuda porque dói
demais
mas aí a gente conta com a família
os próximos nem tão próximos e todo
mundo aparece para nos ajudar mas a
gente tem que estar aberto para receber
bem como os grupos de apoio de perdas
formas a todos os oportunistas da dis da
gente
compartilhar aquele momento que sangrava
tanto que não foi uma surpresa quando
diante de todos os 1 com lojistas que
cuidaram da nossa filha
o de nova york veio ao brasil com razões
profissionais e pediu para nos conhecer
e foi esse o oncologista que nos ensinou
uma reflexão de que anjos que passam por
aqui tão brevemente deixaram sementes
deixaram oportunidades a gente conhecer
melhor seus planos e foi quando eu me
mexer nos guardados da nossa filha e
encontrei o grande amor dela pelo
handebol e olha eu lá querendo ser mãe
de um time de handebol e foi quando a
gente então procurou ressignifica e se
esse ensinamento e essa oportunidade e
foi quando a gente fez eu sim de pelúcia
se transformar no núcleo esportivo que
carrega o nome da juju uma apaixonada
pelo handebol em que a gente acredita
que nós conseguimos mudar a vida de
muitos atletas porque hoje deus me deu a
graça de ter duas filhas biológicas e
104 filhos atletas e eu tenho certeza
que quando eles jogam eles
todas as vezes que esse ponto que a
gente acompanha os treinos nos jogos
eles olham para o céu e mandando o ponto
da vitória para a estrelinha que está no
céu e eu tenho certeza tem o sonho de
onde estiver e fica batendo palma também
né
isso foi um ressignificado pra nós que o
coletivo salva e avisou muricy também eu
acho que eu fui uma mãe de ouro nesse
momento e aí a gente entende que a gente
vem pra essa passagem para aprender e
vocês não imaginam que quando a gente
está nos jogos eu ganho 104 beijos né
mas eu estaria muito bom ter esse beijo
de novo mas ao invés de brigar com esse
fato que não é possível eu resolvi a
ampliar a minha gratidão e agradecer
pelos 18 anos que o juiz teve comigo
deteve escolhido para ser mãe dela e ter
me ensinado tanto ensinado a estar aqui
hoje
então eu só tenho a agradecer a
oportunidade
obrigada desejo queria combinar com
vocês
isaura cooper servirá como é
besouros nos propõe é uma atividade
diária
ela não pode ser pensada só quando tá
doendo
então eu queria convidar vocês a
entender um pouco mais sobre os touros e
que a gente possa a cada dia sempre que
possível a cada momento fácil difícil
que a gente teve a esperança de tesoura
muito bem
[Aplausos]